un parón en los enfrentamientos en la
carretera que traía análisis sean nos
permitió entrar hasta esta población que
si bien sigue en control de las fuerzas
ucranianas pues está en constante
disputa la ciudad está prácticamente
sola nos hemos encontrado con algunos
ciudadanos que dicen que el respiro en
la batalla les ha permitido salir y
hacer la compra a hacer lo que tienen
que hacer incluso nos hemos encontrado
con personas que están se acerca a la
estación de bomberos esperando que venga
ayuda humanitaria para llevarlos y
sacarlos de la ciudad de ésta no ha
llegado hoy el acceso hasta la ciudad es
muy complicado casi imposible y pues lo
que nos hemos encontrado es no solamente
destrucción muchísimos edificios
destruidos se ve que hay bombardeos y
también hay artillería sino que también
nos hemos encontrado pues que la ciudad
cada vez está más aislada y cada vez
corre más peligro de caer en control de
las fuerzas rusas que están cada más
cerca